am 14 dezember 1990 statt der
schriftsteller maler und denker
friedrich dürrenmatt über das was uns
seither fehlt über den menschen
dürrenmatt und über das was von ihm
bleiben wird diskutiere ich heute mit
sabine gisiger autorin des films türen
hat eine liebesgeschichte und dem
dürrenmatt biografen peter rüedi
herzlich willkommen herr diese annahme
habe ich am 28 november 1990 also kurz
verwirrung hat tod noch ein langes
gespräch mit ihm geführt wie ist ihnen
dieses gespräch in erinnerung geblieben
sehr eindrücklich und es war nicht nur
ein tag wo ich in neuenburg sein durfte
mit dem reden sondern es waren drei
aufeinanderfolgenden tagen und das
wahrzeichen für seine genialität denn
sein zustand war in dieser zeit nicht
der beste er war müde
nach der berühmten haben rede das war
eine woche drauf und er hatte gleich
eine ganze reihe von interviews hinteren
handel zu absolvieren
und ich war eigentlich sehr gerührt dass
er es ist zu diesem gespräch bereit fand
und ich war dann auch sehr beeindruckt
über die substanz dessen was er in
seiner besonderen art der allmählichen
verfertigung der gedanken beim reden mir
erzählt habe das ist das sind sehr
verschlungene harten des nachdenkens
wenn man mit dem hat sprach und und ein
ende war nicht immer abzusehen obwohl er
immer zurück kam auf positionen die man
selber als fragen schon wieder vergessen
hatte
in dieser hinsicht war das ein besonders
eindrückliches gespräch kaum zu
transkribieren also vom journalistischen
medien besonders schwierig lang musste
man musste diese gespräche
rekonstruieren recht eigentlich
sie haben eine andere beziehung zu
diesen maxi haben nach seinem leben
einen film über dürrenmatt gemacht sie
kennt man für ihr interesse an hiphop an
gurus an verseuchten gebieten nun sind
sie in dürrenmatts universum
eingestiegen warum ich glaube er war für
mich eigentlich seit vielen vielen
jahren der wichtigste denken denn wir
hatten in der schweiz und ich habe mich
sehr oft bei ihm inspiriert also ich
interessiere mich übrigens nicht in dem
sinn für verseuchte gebiete aber gerade
bei diesem film zum beispiel in seveso
da ging es um einen menschen der
verantwortlich gemacht wurde für das
erste dioxin unglück und da habe ich mir
auch überlegen müssen wie stelle ich ihn
da was ist das für eine figur und habe
dann auch wieder einig bei dürrenmatt
der lösung gefunden der darüber schreibt
was ein held in dem irrwitzigen
zwanzigsten jahrhundert aber auch 21
jahrhundert eigentlich noch sein kann
als er hat mich immer inspiriert jetzt
wissen wir von ihnen adidas ihre
beschäftigung für die biografie an
diesem führt von jürgen hat mindestens
20 jahre gebraucht hat sie sind auch
noch nur bis zur hälfte gekommen bis zu
seinem 16 30 altersjahr sie haben jetzt
relativ schnell etwas gemacht zu dem
motto lässt sie dürrenmatt wieder los
können sie zum nächsten thema oder
glauben sie dass jetzt auch 20 jahre
muss ich ihn in schutz nehmen er hat
nicht mit dem sechsten dreißigsten
lebensjahr aufgehört weil das buch immer
ja auch ausflüge macht in sein
alterswerk insofern lernt man den ganzen
dürrenmatt kennen in diesem buch ich
liebe es sehr darum sage ich das jetzt
und hat die frage vergessen dass frage
war ob sie sich wieder befreien können
von kirchen hat möchte ich gar nicht ich
glaube er wird mich durchs leben
begleiten
also ich lese wirklich immer mal wieder
was nicht
die alte dame oder die physiker oder der
richter und sein henker hat so viele
gedanken auch aufgeschrieben und es gibt
sehr spannende gespräche mit ihm die
alle aufgeschrieben sind weil er du hast
das ein bisschen beschrieben vor in
einer war der laut gedacht hat oder
eigentlich beim reden herausgefunden hat
was er denkt und da gibt es sehr viel
dazu und das finde ich sehr inspirierend
und leider auch aktuell darauf werden
wir sicher zu sprechen kommen die
aktualität von dürfen macht wenn wir
jetzt aber diese sunny dürrenmatt uns
uns vergegenwärtigen 25 jahre seit er
gestorben ist das ist mehr als eine
generation es gibt also viele junge
menschen in der schweiz die nicht mehr
dieses direkte bild von dürrenmatts über
das fernsehen das radio oder ihn
getroffen haben diesen dürrenmatt kennen
wie reagieren die jungen jetzt auch auf
das medium film das ja ein schnelleres
medium aktuelles medium ist als
vielleicht literaturraum man immer
klagen kann das niemand mehr liest die
haben junge zuschauer auf jungs gegen
reagiert ich kann jetzt nichts haben
dass ich sehr viele junge zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer erlebt habe aber zum
beispiel meine tochter des 23 die fand
das sehr faszinierend weil es ist
natürlich eine möglichkeit über einen
film leichter zugänglich in ein
universum einzusteigen und wenn man
dürrenmatt als typ erlebt so saftig und
deftig wer ist dann glaube ich schon
dass das auch für junge leute eine
anziehungskraft haben kann
apropos saftig und recht als das ist
wenn ich das sagen darf im übrigen große
vorzug dieses films er verleitet dazu
sich auch lesend mit
zu beschäftigen da ist ein großer anreiz
vor allem für leute die nicht schon ein
vorwissen haben von diesem auto und es
ist ja auch für mich immer ein eintritt
nur schon der titel ist ja etwas was
überrascht
ein paar effekt hat weil da werden wir
darauf kommen dürrenmatt und liebe ist
ein spezielles thema eine
liebesgeschichte ist nicht unbedingt
seine stärke als romancier zum beispiel
aber das was sie über diese deftigkeit
gesagt haben da gibt es einen kleinen
fast wie ein sketch in ihrem film
natürlich material fand footage material
und diesen diese kleine sequenz wollen
wir uns anschauen zu dürfen macht
ist das schon der woche als
forschungsgruppe in zwei grad lag der
spitze ist eben erzählt ich habe es
gesagt ist er fast ein sketch delegiert
jürgen marcus und produziert und alles
von dürrenmatt istrien das groteske das
fantastische der humor ist drin
auch quasi vielleicht sogar das subtile
ist darin in dieser grotesken situation
weil hier sitzt ein zuckerkranker mensch
der mehrere herzinfarkte hinter sich
gehabt hat und man sieht ihm quasi beim
selbstmord zu oder also wenn man seine
platte gegessen hat dann gnade ihm gott
da schießt ganz vieles zusammen in
dieser kleinen szene wie sie wie sie
richtig sagen einmal einmal das
vergnügen am rollenspiel das ist
natürlich nicht der original hat das
heißt es ist auch der original düren hat
aber er spielt eine rolle
dann ist hier zu sehen seine faszination
über für große mengen das betrifft
keineswegs nur das intuitive sondern das
betrifft der stadt heller
na ja nicht das nicht eben eben gerade
denn nichts und der harz ist aufbau tor
spezialisiert wegen der von ihnen
genannten zuckerkrankheit er behalten es
hätte weniger zucker an bord als in
anderen weil ja es stimmt dass ein
das sind durch geborene in der regel in
der welt zumindest in der damaligen zeit
und diese diese lust an der darstellung
eine rolle die bei seiner ganzen
sonstigen vor intimitäten und vor
persönlichen verlautbarungen hier
deutlich sichtbar wird es ist es ist
sozusagen eine selbstdarstellung
dürrenmatts als ball nach sein kommissar
warum ist er heißt bei ihm
der anschluss von der richter und sein
henker ist ein opfer bei einem ungeheuer
aus lathen nachtmahl überführt sind sie
im land heute abend nicht kenne ja aber
das ist das wird uns sicher noch
beschäftigen in unserem gespräch quasi
die frage nach dem ich die frage nach
der rolle und jemand wie dürrenmatt der
der masten auch als eine rolle gefallen
ist also aus einer solchen literarischen
schweizer tradition rolle hinaus
gefallen ein unikum ein solitär gewesen
ist die frage nach dem fehlt uns das in
der schweiz heute also dieser diese
figur dürrenmatt meine sie jetzt eher
oder eine andere figur die eine rolle
spielt in unserer gesellschaft für sich
gespielt das vermischt sich ja ein
bisschen will ich weiß gar nicht ob man
das so gut vergleichen kann weil es
total andere zeiten sind und auch die
art wie sie kommuniziert wird oder wie
provoziert wird ganz anders läuft kann
mir weiß nicht aber konzept dürrenmatt
vorstellen der auf facebook jeden tag
was kluges postet uns damit uns
produzieren provoziert kann ich mir
schwer vorstellen obwohl er mit der zeit
eine gewisse vorliebe für einige
verlautbarungen entwickelt hat ganz ganz
ganz im gegensatz zu seiner sonstigen
vorliebe für intimität und seiner und
seiner schreibe er an einzelne der
schweizer wird frei geboren aber dann
tritt er in das geschäftsleben ein
das ist so ein satz ist heute diejenigen
die nicht an den zufall glauben werden
umso härter von ihm getroffen ja
eigentlich sehr viele seine grund
erkenntnisse dann in so boos gefasst
obwohl ich ebenso in einem interview
gehört habe dass er gesagt hat eine
schlimmste vorstellung wäre dass er
einmal so in einem kalender mit kalender
sprüchen erscheint aber der hat ja trost
beide ja das war's eine
schreckensvorstellung aber gleichzeitig
hat er eigentlich viele von dieser
diesen bonus geprägt und ich gemerkt
habe auch immer wieder wiederholt also
in robust sein
ein anderes ist die ganze welt ist eine
pulverfabrik und alle rauchen
das ist auch zum beispiel so ein eines
dieser borussia diese diese schlagworte
haben dann auch zuweilen ganz jahren in
die irre geführt wenn sie sich auf die
dramaturgie bezogen also der satz eine
geschichte ist dann zu ende erzählt wenn
sie die schlimmstmögliche wendung
genommen hat das ist natürlich für einen
dramatiker der von sich behauptet er
arbeite nicht didaktisch sondern
induktiv ins blaue hinein ist als eine
merkwürdige aussage ein
die schlimmstmögliche wendung ist ein
superlativ und ein endpunkt und wenn
eine geschichte nur dann erzählt ist
dann muss man ein stück vom ende her
konstruieren von dieser
schlimmstmöglichen wenn es heißt
natürlich auch da kommen wir haben aber
da werden wir haben leider nur eine
stunde nicht
20 jahre noch einmal zum kommentieren
genau aber zu sagen dass wenn quasi die
schlimmstmögliche wendung das ist ja
eine auch eine soll sagen eine haltung
eben zu sagen der liebe gott ist ein
benzin gibt ein großer zyniker der mit
großem humor auf unsere welt hinunter
schaut und zeigt und und freude hat dass
der mensch sich selber in diesem dieser
pulverfabrik in die luft jagt und das
wäre dann so der große unterschied weiß
nicht was zu bertolt brecht gedacht hat
oder man kann den menschen irgendwo
verbessern und in eine gute wendung
hineinbringen das ist wie die absage
dieses dieses solitäre auch diese lust
am grotesken des absurden und das meine
ich könnte doch etwas sein was uns fehlt
die lust am grotesken war in dem sie
nicht nur eine lust sondern für ihn wie
wie zwingend weil er einfach überzeugt
war dass wir uns eine welt der
katastrophen bauen
und weil er weil es weil es sein versuch
war der welt ein gesicht ab zu zwingen
und dieses gesicht das er dann gezeigt
hat das fehlt uns das danke dass er
vielen dank und aber auch das natürlich
gesagt was nie ist dieses gesicht und da
ist dieser film ausschnitt dieser kleine
auch noch einmal wichtig es ist nämlich
die komödie die diesen grotesken treiben
auf der welt das einziges noch irgendwo
ein gesicht geben kann
die tragikkomödie aber das ist nicht
mehr der intellektuelle der quasi kraft
seiner seiner intelligenz seines
intellekts regiert sondern im thema
dinge zeigt also dass eine diagnose
gestellt und sei sie noch so schlecht
seien sie noch so kassandra haft aber
kein therapeut ist er ist lustig und
nicht therapeut und diese these dass
eigentlich die unwirklichkeit des realen
lebens dass die bühne gar nicht
hinterherkommt eine unwirklichkeit zu
schaffen die so grotesk ist wie die
wirklichkeit des realen lebens
hat er eigentlich sehr früh nach den
physikern glaube ich schon in den 60er
jahren behauptet und das hat sich für
ihn eigentlich je länger je mehr
bestätigt das blieb für ihn ein thema
das wir menschen so viel wissen wir
wissen auch was wir eigentlich tun
müssten und tun trotzdem dass das
gegenteil also diese frage die nimmer
beschäftigt hat wie macht man aus dem
rumpf aus dem raub auf ein mensch einen
humanen menschen
das hat ihn aus frage beschäftigt in
seinen stücken aber er hat keine
eindeutige antwort darauf dass das es
gibt es gibt eine großartige stelle wo
er davon spricht dass eigentlich die
rettung des planeten die das
verschwinden des rauben menschen sei
also der untergang des menschen ist die
voraussetzung für das überleben des
planeten
das ist das ist ganz ganz identisch zu
dem was heiner müller
die negative utopie nennt und einer
merkwürdigen er jetzt zwischen zwei
autoren die sonst nicht allzu viel
miteinander gemein haben
und da gibt es ein ungeheures futurum
exakt um von dort das tollste futurum
exakten dass ich in der literatur kenne
das heißt der mensch wird etwas
ungeheures wunderbares und einmaliges
gewesen sein
der und sie erklärt was ein fuß um exakt
zum ja und das gilt sozusagen auch für
die figur und für das einzel besen
dürner und da da möchte ich ein bisschen
einhacken weil ich glaube in ihren
vielen dürmer deine liebesgeschichte
beziehen sie sich gehen sie auf diesen
menschen die an parteien in einer
speziellen situation am schluss seines
lebens als witwe die symbiotische
beziehung zu seiner frau loth die nimmt
ein trauriges tragisches ende
und es beginnt noch einmal etwas damit
haben wir auch noch einmal den blick auf
den tod also ein teil von dürrenmatt
stirbt mit lotti und es gibt eine
sequenz ganz zu anfang des films war
über den tod nachdenke und was passiert
nach dem tod eines menschen und das
möchten wir uns kurz anschauen gehen
der tod ändert alles
das vergangene versteht sich nicht mehr
von selbst
doch hier weiter wir von einem menschen
weg getrieben werden der durch den tod
in der zeit zurück bleibt desto mehr
nimmt er in unserer erinnerung gestalten
[Musik]
also man sieht ist ihren markt als drama
zurück als als dramatiker kann sein
leben gestalten und kontroll und spielen
bis zum schluss bis zur havel rede
unglaublich präzise er ins leben hinein
greifen
jetzt ist er tot und es ist wie mit dem
tod von lotti jetzt kann man mit
dürrenmatt besser als zu lebzeiten
umgehen zumindest anders oder als er
sagt er selber nach dem tod gestalten
wir das bild eines menschen nach unseren
eigenen vorstellungen
das denke ich auch du hast ihm versucht
so nahe wie möglich zu kommen ich habe
das versucht aber letztlich sind ja dass
versuche als eine subjektive perspektive
das bringt mich auf den gedanken dass
der antrag meiner biografie ursprünglich
ein ganz anderer war der plan war mit
ihm die gespräche die wir angefangen
haben in neuchatel fortzuführen nach der
rückkehr von seiner weltreise und dann
so etwas zu machen wie das was die
amerikaner biografie ist tot osama
nennen ich wollte das eigentlich mit ihm
zusammen im gespräch entwickeln und das
was in den stoffen sehr stilisiert und
sehr distanziert gemäß einer ganzen
ästhetik an biografie vorkommt ein
bisschen vom kopf auf die füße stellen
in diesem gespräch und plante das
eigentlich diese biografie mit dem
lebenden dürrenmatt und standorten genau
vor diesem dilemma
die allmähliche veränderung eines
lebenden menschen in einen literarischen
gegenstand sozusagen im lauf der arbeit
zu erleben und das
das bedeutete natürlich einige
umstellungen in der taktik mal abgesehen
von dem riesen material an quellen also
erst noch sein und dort zum vorschein
kam
so stehen sie ja klar und das finde ich
auch wieder interessantes gab 1965 sein
legendäres fernsehgespräch als die
beiden kritiker reich ranicki und meier
extra nach zürich gepilgert sind haben
wie sie im eingang des gespräche sagen
ali nicht im sturm teile mit den siegern
ist beginn der aschenbecher beginnt zu
breiten türen wort redet über
aristoteles weiter und sagt dass jetzt
müssen wir über mehr reden und der roman
g t und reich ranicki beging sie putzt
das eine wunderbare fernseh ein
wunderbares fernsehmoment aber was da
drin sagt und das würde mich
interessieren weil er eine art von
sehnsucht geäußert hat in der in der
inter sieht in der beziehung zwischen
kritiker und autor und dass er sagt dass
dies zu weit auseinander sind und dass
nur manchmal funken schlagen jetzt sind
sie nicht in der beide nicht in der
rolle des kritikers aber sie sind
rezipienten professionelle menschen die
mit diesem planeten mit diesem universum
umgehen und er hat sich glaube ich
gesehen da hat so etwas gesagt wie das
kritiker sollten näher beim auto sein
und hat sich wie gesehnt nach gesprächen
nach diesem austausch und dieser solitär
dürrenmatt hat ja das hat man auch an
vielen stellen spürt man dass probleme
gehabt aber nicht ein talentierter
gesprächsführung sowie frisch weil sie
jeden vielleicht eher in prinzipien in
konstellationen auskannte als im intimen
austausch und seine erfahrung war immer
das selbstgespräch
wer auch immer gegenüber saß er führte
selbstgespräche
also das heißt diese sehnsucht nach
einer intimität oder nach einem echo
konnte er gar nicht selber einlösen das
ist ja auch eine wenn man jemandem wir
ihn ja logisch wenn man und für mich war
das ein großes glück jetzt für den film
auf ihn selber über sich habe
brechen lassen wollen dass es ja viel
vieles habe ich von dir gekriegt anderes
gesucht insgesamt hatte ich 80 stunden
wo dürrenmatt spricht weil er halt sehr
oft mit mit mit journalisten für das
radio fürs fernsehen gesprochen hat und
dann kam eine frage und dann hat er
geredet und ist jetzt noch einmal der
theatermensch dürrenmatt der vermutlich
sehr genau wusste was die rolle einer
kamera spielte also zu sagen man kann
dieses ich in der kamera anders
darstellen weil man aus der kammer
heraus über eines sprechen kann
als die kamera kann eine art von
identität haben die war dass wenn man
mit ihm ohne kamera war ja es war nicht
ein prinzipieller unterschied
er spielte auch im persönlichen gespräch
immer mal wieder verschiedene rollen
so gesehen er war ein er war ein großer
kamera skeptiker und zwar auch aus
gründen der intimität eine großaufnahme
hielt er grundsätzlich für eine
obszönität wir irgendwo mal sagte
und er hat war alles andere als kamera
gar keine rampensau
obwohl solche auftritte wie wir sie
gesehen haben
mit hans lässt diese vermutung nahelegt
da war das ist nicht so
er hatte eine vorliebe für deftige
auftritte aber er drängt
er drängte nicht an die rampe obwohl ja
nicht ob wohl aber dass es trotzdem in
diese in ihrem film sehr intime momente
gibt deshalb vermutlich hat er schon mit
dem zu tun wie sie mit diesem material
dann umgegangen sind und diese diese
stellung gefunden haben was mich das hat
mit der montage zu tun höher ist ja
vielleicht interessant also das meiste
was ich gehört habe war radio und in die
in diesem ganzen vielen stunden hat er
nie über etwas privates oder über etwas
intimes gesprochen und zwar gingen diese
80 stunden von den späten 50ern bis eine
woche vor seinem tod wo er ja mit hugo
loetscher noch gesprochen hat einmal hat
er über seine innenleben ihnen auf eine
intime art und weise gesprochen in einem
kurzen radiointerview einen monat nach
dem tod von lot im januar 1983 und da
kommen zwei journalisten von schweizer
radio und der ware wahrscheinlich so
aufgewühlt dass er das vergessen hat und
wirklich etwas von sich erzählt hat und
immer wenn wenn solche intimeren
aussagen über wie es ihm geht dem film
sind sind die alle aus dem gleichen
gespräch
es gibt eine stelle die mich sehr
beeindruckt hat die stelle über die
selbstzweifel so dass der dichterfürst
hoch über neuenburg der alles außer dem
nobelpreis gewonnen hat dass er so etwas
sagt wie wir uns das anschauen können
die schreibe eigentlich andrews und ich
glaube ich schreibe ein drama schreib
ich ja vielleicht zehn mal und zwar
beginne ich ein stück solange es
eigentlich geht und bis ich nicht mehr
weiter kann dann einfach nicht wieder
von vorn hat dann geht das sieht man
jetzt das weit
seitlich ist dass schreiber mit so
vielen bescheid verbunden und mit soviel
auch persönlich mit
minderwertigkeitsgefühl mann ist eine
ständige neben der unsicherheit
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich den richtigen
beruf zu machen ist die für lichte auch
bundles sind so
[Musik]
also als ich diese stelle der tochter
ruth und dem sohn peter dürrenmatt
gezeigt habe das motiv als ich den film
gezeigt haben sie haben diese stelle
gehört das war etwas von dem was sie am
meisten berührt hat weil weil sie gesagt
haben dass er diese unsicherheit nie
geäußert oder gezeigt hätte da waren sie
ganz überrascht das zuhören weil er hat
verschiedene rollen gespielt aber lieber
ein bisschen puttrich als als sich in
die seele blicken zu lassen und
unsicherheit zu geben und dafür die
kinder hat er das was schönes das
zuhören
es ist sehr überraschend diese passage
berührte auch mich sehr
ebenso wie die vorangehende der
vorangehende ausschnitt über den tod
das sind das hinter ausnahmen wo er eine
solche nähe zugelassen hat die größten
dinge über den tod den glauben
die liebe hat der öffentliche äußerungen
geschaut wie der teufel das weihwasser
deshalb frage ich auch wenn du mir
gestattet ist ein bisschen irritiert
über den fokus seines films über den
untertitel der ja wenn ich das recht
sicher erst in einem zweiten anlauf dazu
gekommen ist eine liebesgeschichte die
liebesgeschichte ist in der eigenen
wahrnehmung von dürrenmatt eine
angelegenheit die nicht in die
öffentlichkeit gehört das ist eine frage
des anstands wird als mir gegenüber auch
mal geäußert hat in ganz konventionellen
sinn dafür eine eine frage vielleicht
anknüpfen weil einer das dich worte in
diesem ausschnitt war für mich
persönlich das wort persönlich
da macht er wieder drückt den knopf mit
diesem wort und wird persönlich auch
und jetzt diese liebesgeschichte sie
persönlich also das ist ja auch ein
dialog mit jemandem den sie mit 80
stunden material sprechen hören der
monologisiert wie zu lebzeiten und sie
holen sich als eigenständige regisseurin
autorin einen einen gesprächspartner aus
dieser vergangenheit ist dass die
liebesgeschichte alles verstehen
natürlich ja
das verstehe ich sehr gut das ist der
punkt
ja und es hat ja auch damit zu tun dass
ich ja mit ihm kein gespräch geführt
habe aber sie haben das schön gesagt auf
eine art doch weil ich mir zumindest die
antworten gesucht aussuchen durfte oder
nach antworten suchen durfte
und wie ein filter funktionieren und den
dingen nachgehen
die mich interessieren und gerade weil
er intime so gescheut hatte sich in die
seele blicken lassen hat das bei mir
auch neugier geweckt irgendwie doch in
diese seele zu sehen nicht bloßstellen
skandalträchtig sondern wie diese feine
seite irgendwie doch auch zu entdecken
und es gibt eine andere voller intimität
die ihm selbstverständlich wenn man zu
sagen will unterläuft das ist die
intimität dieser stimme wenn man sich 80
stunden lang wie du beschäftigt hat und
immer diese stimme im ohr hat dieses
schwere berndeutsch entweder-oder dieses
berndeutsch applizierte hochdeutsch mit
einer ganz eigenen melodieführung das
hat etwas außerordentliches intimes und
auch und auch berührendes und auch
verführerisch
und da will ich sie sagt ja der sound
genauer original sound von dürrenmatts
stimme ist etwas sehr besonderes und
hier habe ich eine seine mutige adhoc
theorie ehre sie können gleich
zurückschlagen
ich habe den eindruck türen hat in
seiner ganzen souveränität noch einmal
in diesem gespräch 19 65 mit den beiden
politikern sie sehen so kleinanzeigen
ich jetzt retrospektiv oder diebe
versuchen diese festung einzunehmen und
braucht türen und man kriegt dürrenmatt
intellektuell nicht geboten
man muss intimität aufbauen muss
körperwerte neben die sprache der körper
dürrenmatt dürrenmatt minotaurus der
sich nach etwas sehen nein gegenüber
da aber dieses gegenüber kaputt macht
und zerfetzt
dass diese liebesgeschichte doch etwas
ist was nicht ein tabu bricht weil man
jetzt intimes über dürrenmatt erzählt
sondern wenn man sagt wenn wir nach dem
tod über jemanden reden sowie die ohren
mal dass über lud die sagt reflektiert
dann müssen wir beginnen mit dem bauch
dürrenmatt zu begreifen und uns mit dem
bauch an dürrenmatt annähernd ich meine
theorie ja das unterschreibe ich absolut
natürlich auch sein denken hat
außerordentlich sinnliche züge natürlich
und sein denken strebt immer ins
konkrete nämlich ins erzählerische über
das gleichnis
das ist der entscheidende punkt in
seiner ästhetik dass er erkenntnisse
nicht abstrakt formuliert sondern in
gleichnisse umsetzt also in stoffe der
stoff ist so ein zwischen begriff
zwischen welt und seiner person und
seinem in leeden also der stoff ist
eigentlich eine grenze stoff ist materie
ist so fliesst materie hat aber nichts
mit dem zu tun was man einen
literarischen stoffen im konventionellen
sehen nennen würde also dass einer sich
bei einem mythos bedient das hat jürgen
hat auch getan
aber nur wenn sie es das deckte mit
einem bereich von eigenen erfahrungen
das labyrinth war nicht eine keine
kulturelle erfindung eine eine die die
findung eines top aus sondern es
entwicklers bild entwickelte sich als
klausel gingen aus konolfingen
ursprünglich mal und dann vor allem eine
umsetzung seines seiner bayern erfahrung
seiner stadt kobe eher waren
stadtneurotiker in hohem maße gesagt das
labyrinth erfüllte sich selber im
labyrinth weil er sich aus nicht
orientieren konnte zumal in der stadt
nicht wo er mit als 14-jähriger
hingekommen ist hat er sich versucht in
seinem inneren zu orientieren in dem er
gestaltet und formt was er in seinem
innern hat aber das heißt also quasi
noch einmal
es muss jetzt ein bisschen auf meine
weine schöne theorie
naja wenn man sagt sie reden vom stoff
wir haben von der vernunft gerettet wir
uns alle übertrumpft sensibel wird und
und verschieden wert und interessant
wird natürlich für uns jetzt im 21
jahrhundert vielleicht auch ist dort wo
die vernunft der stadt sich auflöst
verloren geht und in eine art unvernunft
oder fantasie oder stofflichkeit sich
verwandelt in der es eben vielleicht
doch um beziehungen geht um liebe geht
um intimität geht und dass wir diese
isolation knacken in dem wir uns doch an
diese nebenbeschäftigung mit diesen
beziehungen diesen konstellationen sie
haben das über lustig gemacht seine frau
jetzt gibt es aber natürlich wenn man
das sagt dann ist das nicht eine nur
intellektuelle beziehung wie zwischen
lofer und sarah sonstigen das ist eine
physische beziehung und diese beziehung
ist auch geprägt über die nachtzeiten
dieser beziehung die die depressiven
seiten von lotti in dieser symbiotischen
beziehung natürlich irgendwo dann auch
bei dürrenmatt also lassen sie uns ein
bisschen über die nachtzeiten von
dürrenmatt sprechen über die nachtzeiten
verhandlung dieser beziehung mit lotti
wie wenig bekannt geworden sind zu
seinen lebzeiten weil das paar hat hat
sich selbst und die familie überhaupt
vehement abgeschottet ab dem moment
wurde eine öffentliche eine person des
öffentlichen interesses wurde also ab
der alten dame die pc und zwar aber früh
oder das ist dass das war für die
beziehung war auch schon früh recht
prekär weil auf der einen seite
lotti das gefühl haben musste sie hätte
ihm und der familie und dem unterhalt
der von ihm in seinem kreativen autismus
vernachlässigten familie ihre karriere
und ihr eigenleben und ihre spiele in
jedem laufbahn geopfert als
schauspielerin
eine hair aussage die ich die ich
bezweifle weil eine große schauspielerin
charlotte türen ab nicht aber wer hat es
denn gesagt das lässt sich aus dem
schließen wie sie von vw zu und ginsberg
am basler theater eingesetzt wurde dass
also da
das lässt sich schon schließen und sie
war eine äußerst charmante person und in
diesem film ist verinnerlicht wie hisste
aber sie hat nicht so gut gespielt und
also ein die versionierung firma
deutlich wird ist natürlich eben diese
fixation dieser beiden eltern in diesem
elternhaus in der jlu wie sie der
einfluss auf die arbeiten die figuren
die personen die dürrenmatt verwendet
gehabt hat da gibt es eine sehr schöne
sequenz wo peter erzählt über beides
über die beziehung seiner eltern und
über die rolle der mutter für die
ratsarbeit
[Musik]
wie eigentlich verbaute bis heute
gestorben
daneben liefert der findung wird der
unter vertrag mit xamax ich gerne wenn
sie proben und so sehr oft mühselig sehr
verdammt konzentriert sich das ist sehr
liter schafft serie sind nicht
miteinander gesprochen
mit besonnenheit personenstimmen
eingeschätzt regiert das ist die logik
von der figur meinte scherzhaft ich bin
vater nie die fischtown sechs ihrer
recherche wird die vergangene woche
video passt und ersparte zu schmieden
und klipp und klar
und das hätte hier sind nicht dieser
figur lehrgang stück von ihm vater war
also das heißt da war eine kleine fabrik
arbeiten ja da zumindest das war diese
kreative sicher erfüllen der seite der
beziehung und wir haben sie ja vorhin
gesagt er kommt der gedanken entwickeln
und scherzen ihm reden und eine
gesprächspartnerin zu haben das war für
ihn essenziell dass das auf der anderen
seite für lotti auch verzicht bedeutet
hat auf eigenes oder das denke ich ist
schon
klar sie haben das kurz angesetzt am
anfang also quasi die karriere von
dürrenmatt die beginnt ja nicht als
weltauto und volks geht dann halt
schnell aber er sagt im film ja auch ein
mann braucht ein muss einen karren
ziehen damit irgendwo in schwung kommt
japan war diese familie das war seine
seine auffassung dass sein dass man geld
verdienen muss dass er sich durchbringen
muss das hat sich auch mit seinem
familiären hintergrund zu tun eine
höchst protestantischen erfassung und
aber das hat das sehr gut gemacht und es
ist ihm nicht schlecht bekommen hat ja
für geld sehr gute dinge gemacht aber es
gibt im film wie auch nochmals einen
narrativen bruch es gibt einerseits
dieser karren den erzieht und er sagte
aber schon als witwer war keinen karren
mehr zu ziehen hat 1983 alleine hockt
und dieser dieser dieser ballast fehlt
und dann sagt das etwas an solle keine
pläne machen im leben denn das sei
lächerlich
das ist ein aber ein anderer dürrenmatts
der hier spricht ja das ist der
dürrenmatt der das haltende macht des
zufalls nicht nur in seiner ästhetik
sondern auch im realen leben entdeckt
und erfahren hat nicht er hat auch
diesen tod von logic zuerst ja gar nicht
glauben können er kam an das bett und
hatte zum arzt sieht sie sieht aus wie
tod und der arzt sagte ihm sie ist tot
und nachher hat er immer ich habe ihn in
dieser zeit regelmäßig gesehen weil wir
am schauspielhaus acht euro gemacht
haben sein
sein letztes stück und der war in einer
desolaten verfassung
das muss man schon sagen er hat immer
gesagt sie hat mir einen bösen streich
gespielt wie ein kind das von seiner
mutter verlassen wird
und zwar wiederholt das war seine form
für viel für dieses erleben
seine trauer äußerte sich zuerst in
einem gefühl des verlassen werden also
fast in einer anklage gegenüber der
verstorbenen auch sehr merkwürdigen
recht und sind dieses vakuum diese
isolation des grundsätzlicher bereits
isolierten menschen dürrenmatt peter
sagt das ja auch einmal im film der
seine facetten dann noch einen zaun in
dieses haus um dieses haus herum gezogen
das hoch über natürlich wo man auch
schon nicht mehr als ein fuchs ein hasen
trifft in der regel bloss zwei streifen
hunde die auch noch den letzten rest von
besuchen fernhielten und gelegentliche
besuche spitalreif
auch das kann noch dazu also in diese
isolation bricht ein
charlotte kerr wir wissen wie das genau
gegangen ist weil charlotte kerr ein
buch geschrieben hat die frau im roten
mantel
sie hat ihn kennengelernt bei maximilian
schell
er war befreundet mit dürrenmatt hatte
auch 1975 eine verfilmung gemacht von
der richter und sein henker und weil es
so auch gegen ward auf traut ihren
marktauftritt ja und in dieser
resolution also nach dem tod von lotti
hat er sich oft nach münchen geflüchtet
und hat dann bei seinem freund
maximilian schell übernachtet und
gewohnt und irgendwann mal hatte der
eben auch schon brauchte den mal eine
pause und hat die charlotte kerr
angerufen ob sie nicht kommen möchte und
eine an adendorfer bringen und da haben
sich die beiden kennengelernt und nach
dieser nacht war dürrenmatt auch für sie
monologisiert hat und erzählt hat um
geschichte gesponnen war sie so
fasziniert dass sie beschlossen hat
einen film über ihn zu machen ist noch
nie chatel hat diesen langen vielen mit
ihm gedreht der waren nicht
alleine hatte wieder ein gegenüber und
diese wahnsinnige verliebtheit hat ihn
dann aus dem loch gerettet und ja dort
siehst du so das heißt man spürt nach
der blick durch die kamera hindurch auch
zu zur kamerafrau gewissermaßen was ich
habe gerne noch zur sprache bringen
möchte wenn wir bei den beziehungen
gewesen sind nicht jetzt speziell auf
die beziehung zu frisch eingehend aber
zu sagen wir haben mit diesen beiden sie
wurden ja auch die ausfuhren genannt
dass er dieses gegen ein paar schiller
goethe frisch dürrenmatt frisch das ist
landläufig der politische oder und
dürrenmatt ist nicht der politische was
ich kenne es an dass in den 70er jahren
da gab's beatles und rolling stones und
frisch und dürrenmatt rolling stones und
dürrenmatt war meistens zusammen und
bietet um frisch also nur weil sie
gesagt haben land glaube ich meine
mitarbeit wir sind wir sind jetzt ein
bisschen beim verliebten alten frische
backwaren werden
ich wollte ihn noch einmal zurückholen
in seinen politischen dürrenmatt der
landläufig nicht so ist
und auch jetzt weil wir den film sehr
über den intimen aspekt von dem mann
gesprochen haben möchte ich noch den
politischen holen um dann auch
vielleicht darzustellen was ja live von
dürrenmatt und da habe ich dann noch mal
eine these aber die haben sie sicher
auch das weiß ich nicht ob sich die
gleiche das eigentliche eine eine
ausstellung also eben den politischen 18
jahren ich meine das war ein das war
ganz lang ein klischee über diese
ungleichen teams cool die ja eigentlich
von außen verklammert worden und
zunächst hauptsächlich in deutschland wo
sie im gleichen moment mehr oder weniger
auf dem theater ausarten
als die beiden schweizer sozusagen als
ersatz besetzung für den damals
verwenden brecht der als ddr staats auto
keine chance hatte auf west- deutschen
bühnen
das spielte auch eine rolle beim aufbau
des ruhms das warum der beiden straßen
als vakuum young sagte er auch
dürrenmatt irgendwo es gab die schule
hatten dichter aber in deren schubladen
war wenig drin und das war der grund für
den aufstieg unserer bekanntheit und das
heißt aber dass also der politik ganz
schnell ja natürlich das nur an sagt
precht ist noch ein dichter der
vorkriegszeit mental und türen markt wie
frisch sind nachkriegs dichter wo seinen
loch gibt und ist etwas verkürzt brecht
war in seinen anfängen natürlich ein
expressionist mit stücken wie wahl und
im dickicht der städte und anderen
dürrenmatt war so etwas wie der letzte
expressionist wir auftauchte mit es
steht geschrieben er war also in
gewisser hinsicht ein unzeitgemäßer um
dieses diesen einstmals etwas modischen
leistung zu gebrauchen
er war ein betrieb ein unzeitgemäßer bis
zum schluss und die diesen diesen
unzeitgemäßer längeren an einem heißen
aber heißt aber nicht dass er sich nicht
um politische zusammenhänge kümmerte nur
nicht in der direkten umsetzung und
polemik in der regel sowie frisch aber
das hat er handelt es hat er einen
wichtigen grund dass er gesagt hat wenn
wenn ich diagnostizieren will wenn ich
beschreiben will was läuft auch
politisch und macht mäßig da muss ich
einen schritt zurücktreten
es sind mitarbeiter distanz
denn distanz also immer wenn wir einen
von der schanze aber schon sagen die
distanz hat ja dann geheißen dass er
sich nicht hat vor einen karren spannen
lassen partei mäßig in der schweiz zum
beispiel
und darum hatte dann eigentlich auch als
unpolitisch gegolten er hat versucht zu
beschreiben oder zu thematisieren in
seinen reden und in seinen schriften was
die dynamik ist dieser welt so wie sie
läuft die dynamik des geldes die gier
die macht
die irrationalität in der politik das
hatte alles beschrieben und sehr klar
und das ganze politische vermächtnis
wenn sie so wollen und die idee
kulminiert doch in dieser hawel rede
kurz vor dem tod die auch immer noch in
unseren köpfen immer noch nach spuckt
ein kleiner aus mit auch hierzu die
schweiz als gefängnis
es gibt nur eine schwierigkeit für
dieses gefängnis nämlich die zu beweisen
dass es kein gefängnis ist sollte ein
hort der freiheit ist doch von außen
gesehen ein gefängnis sein gefängnis und
seine ebenfalls gefangene und
weggefallen ist ist nicht frei gelten
für die außenwelt nur die werte der
werden diese nicht frei wären sie
angefangen
um diesen widerspruch zu lösen für die
gefangenen die allgemeine wehrpflicht
ein
das glauben nächster abschnitt gewählt
wo man ins publikum sieht und auch sieht
dass sie waren ja nicht sehr erfreut
über diese rede in den vorderen reihen
die lacher die man jeweils hört kommt
von hinten das sagt der vroni im film
von den journalisten
also er hat sich damit in einer guten
und inszenierung extrem in die nesseln
gesetzt war nachher beim apéro war
offensichtlich total isoliert und sie
haben erzählt das hat ein nachspiel
gehabt
diese geschichte was mich noch einmal
mehr interessiert also aufs momentum hin
gelesen solch eine novelle räte
dürrenmatt heute jetzt der politische
dürrenmatt heute wo sehen sie ihn in
diesem universellen weil es prinzipielle
die probleme sind in der distanz oder
doch in dieser nähe weil das was er
vorher sagt über die gesellschaft immer
mehr ein zu treffen scheint ja echt ist
ein besonderer fall aus folgendem grund
es wird oft übersehen
man bezieht sie immer auf die fischen
affäre natürlich nicht sagt die
gegenwart also wieso interessiert uns
dürrenmatt heute politisch es ist weil
weil sehen weil es ihm um allgemeine
zusammenhänge geht und um es eine
allgemeine apokalyptischen perspektive
und es gibt wenige leider wenige gründe
diese für überholt zu zu halten wenn man
bedenkt das hauptproblem für ihn waren
ab den 60er jahren nicht die bedrohung
durch die atombombe im nuklearen art des
kalten krieges sondern schon in den
sechziger jahren die überbevölkerung der
erde an der hartz iv bis heute nichts
geändert
überbevölkerung wie er in der basler
rede sagt bei gleichzeitiger extreme
ungerechtigkeit dass es dass es dass es
zu wenige orte gibt wo es gutgeht
reserviert für wenige und der größte
teil der erde wo es nicht gut geht und
würde jetzt wenn die man heute als maler
fungieren würde im tages anzeiger war
seine vision der würde heute über den
charts dann würde den die haut malen
denke er würde die also was wissen wir
aber so vom bild der er diese
flüchtlingsströme weil das für ihn
wirklich auch ein thema war was etwas
passiert mit der weltbevölkerung und er
hat etwa zur gleichen zeit wie die
basler räte die er 1968 gehalten hat hat
er gesagt dass so wie sich die welt
entwickelt wird werden wir also die
westliche gesellschaft uns lösen müssen
von unserem primat der freiheit und
werden ein zum primat der gerechtigkeit
finden müssen um einen ausgleich zu
schaffen amri einer leitmotiv von dürfen
sowieso wieder halen sieht noch viele
hat er das festgestellt er als
individualist und als als
kirkegaard nachfolger einer ethik des
einzelnen an der sich nichts geändert
hat in seinem in seinem ganzen leben
dennoch kam er in diesem aufsatz über
das gesetz der großen zahl hieß aus wo
er ein gesetz der thermodynamik auf die
auf die gesellschaft übertragen
das heißt dass die der diagnostiker
türen markt in dieser fragestellung in
diesem kampf drin zwischen freiheit und
gerechtigkeit richtig prognostiziert hat
dass es in zukunft um gerechtigkeit
gehen wird mit allen konsequenzen und
dass wir in dieser frage drin stecken
mehr es geht um tendenzen
es ist eine polarität zwischen freiheit
und gerechtigkeit das eine gibt es nicht
ohne das andere und es kommt darauf an
wie groß die spuren die spurenelemente
von freiheit in der gerechtigkeits
dominierten notwendig gerechtigkeit
dominierten katastrophen ordnung noch
sein kann
also wir haben mit einem relativ
schweren schluss thema versucht
dürrenmatt irgendwo zu fassen wie zum
schluss und ging nach lust machen da zu
lesen leider keine zeit mehr um zu sagen
was wir lesen von jürgen matthes
behalten wir für uns aber wir halten den
markt den literaten hoch und werden auch
ihn in seinen theaterstücken wieder
treffen
dürrenmatt und kein ende auch die
ratesendung kontext auf sf2 morgen um 9
uhr 0 2 widmet sich dem großen welt
modellbauer und nächsten sonntag spricht
stephan klapproth mit dem ehemaligen
deutschen außenminister joschka fischer
und jetzt bleiben sie dran in der
sternstunde geht es weiter mit der serie
die abenteurer der modernen kunst
[Musik]